[Music]
19
of the last 21 years have been the
hottest years on record
planet earth has already warmed by 1.1
degrees celsius
from the planet on which homo sapiens
evolved
climate change catastrophe is coming
we got through it
have i managed to put any of you to
sleep yet
yawn
[Applause]
i'm bored already with this speech and
it's okay
you can admit it
so are you
so let's reset
communication about climate change
sucks
it all sounds the same
and everybody wants to be al
gore
but in trying to scare people into
taking action
i believe we missed the opportunity to
make the basic point
that there is no better career
than working to address climate change
it checks all the boxes
you hope to build financial security
working climate
in the back you hope to work at the tip
of the spear solve interesting problems
with real world ramifications
work in climate
and you
hope to find meaning in your work
and to be proud of your contributions to
the greater good
working
climate this is not the climate change
talk you've heard a hundred times before
i'm not here to scare you
i'm here to recruit
it is tragic that climate change exists
of course
however
for an individual strategically shaping
their career climate change represents
a once in a lifetime opportunity to
skate where the puck is going on
trillion dollar industries with massive
policy and regulatory tailwinds global
scope but that are somehow still young
enough to have low barriers to
leadership despite enormous almost
guaranteed growth
and at the same time
careers in climate are an opportunity to
pursue work whose impact
will reverberate for generations to come
an opportunity to do well
for yourself
and to do good for those around you
so for the next six minutes
doing well
and doing good
is all i'm going to talk about
first
doing well
climate change
is fundamentally different from any of
the economic mega trends of the past
the steam engine the wheel electricity
steel
the internet
please no one say web3
each of these things happened
and they were important steps forward
for our species
but each of these things just
happened to happen
facebook exists but it wasn't inevitable
that mark zuckerberg would create it
climate change is not like these other
things
because facing climate change is
mathematically
inevitable
either we will beat it
or it will beat us
and inevitability means opportunity
think about how many times in history
have you been able to look
30 years into the future and know with
very little uncertainty which industries
will grow
the logic is extremely simple
either
we lose the fight against climate change
and the economic wheel stops turning
fire
famine
flood
also other f words
either we lose or if we're going to win
and secure a future for our species we
know pretty much which industries will
need to grow
electrify everything and power it with
renewables right
renewable energy
energy storage
regenerative agriculture
decarbonized transport
i could go
on and on
the nascency of these industries also
means
low barriers to leadership for those who
want to get ahead
think of any investment bank
odds are there's a managing director
there
who's been doing some version of that
job for 50 years
how can you or i compete
on the other hand
the electric bus industry
has existed for like five years
which means for any young
smart
ambitious person
like any of you in this room
you have an opportunity to be among the
best in the world
in very little time because the playing
field
it's level
opportunity abounds
for journalists
geologists
policy makers investors
yes for lifeguards because chances are
we're going to have a lot more water
absolutely everyone has something to
gain from participating in the new
economy
and the earlier we get the earlier you
get in
the more valuable you'll be
if you want to do well
work in climate
but isn't life about more than just
doing well
financially
there's an entire other set of criteria
i believe we're all hoping to find it
work
to make the world a better place
and pursue our passions
to help others
to do good
i spent the years before stanford
as a young executive building a solar
microgrid company in southern africa
picture
an urban zambian slum
called inguide during rainy season
tin roofs
thrumming with falling rain
turgid rivers of mud flowing in the
streets
my company had recently installed a
solar microgrid here
this solar microgrid
so one rainy day
i was leading a site visit
and
escaped the rain into someone's home
as the sun set
and darkness settled
this was about the time of day when at
home
here at stanford
i would just turn on the lights
but these people couldn't do that
so it just
got dark
we sat
we waited
and then light
warm light
flooded the home
energizing us all
these people this family
had light
and power
and a better chance at a better life
i can't pretend to know true poverty i
was just a visitor
but for a few moments
i experienced first hand what 800
million people without electricity lived
through
for me this was truly
a light bulb moment
it was a light bulb moment because when
i saw the impact that my work had
on real people
i felt a sense of purpose
i felt that my work
had meaning
i felt that my wife had meaning
it's such a gift to truly believe in
what you do
and i believe strongly that nothing
merits such belief more than preventing
human suffering induced by climate
change
and facing up to the greatest challenge
our species has ever known
if you want to do good
work in climate
but at the end of the day
the beauty of it is
you do not have to choose
between doing well
and doing good
if you choose to work in climate
i'm absolutely convinced it's the best
of both
i'm inspired by the monumental
opportunity to shape the next thousand
years of history
and i'm damn sure
that we need every last one of us
so my friends
i invite you
working climate
thank you
[Music]
you